WITH WHOM CERTAIN MEDIA
ORGANIZATIONS ARE COLLUDING AND
TO WHAT END?
THAT'S THE ANGLE.
ONE PULITZER PRIZE WINNING
JOURNALIST IS SOUNDING THE
ALARGE.
HE'S PAINTING A PICTURE OF WHAT
HAPPENS WITHOUT A FREE AND
HONEST MEDIA.
HE WROTE AN INTERCEPT SAIDING
THE U.S. MEDIA SUFFERED ITS MOST
DEBACLE IN AGES.
WITH US TO GIVE US MORE INSIGHT
IS GREENWALD HIMSELF JOINING US
FROM BRAZIL.
GLENN, IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
RECAP FOR MY AUDIENCE WHAT YOU
WROTE ABOUT OVER THE WEEKEND
ABOUT WHY PARTICULARLY THIS CNN
ISSUE IS SO DISTURBING GIVEN THE
ENORMITY OF THE STORY REGARDING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
RUSSIANS.
>> RIGHT.
SO YOU DESCRIBED EXACTLY HOW THE
STORY FELL APART.
IT IS CERTAINLY THE CASE THAT
ANYONE IN JOURNALISM, WHETHER
SOMETIMES.
THIS IS NOT JUST A BLOCK BUSTER
STORY THAT FELL APART BUT WHAT
IS MOST DISTURBING IS TWO
THINGS.
ONE A LONG LINE NOW OF STORIES
ABOUT TRUMP AND RUSSIA THAT
MAJOR MEDIA OUTLETS HAVE
TRUMPETED IN A FLANNEL BOY --
FLAMBOYANT WAY ONLY TO PROVE
THAT TRUMP DID COLLUDE WITH
RUSSIA AND THAT RUSSIA IS TAKING
OVER THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S NOT ONE MISTAKES IT'S A
HUGE SERIES OF THEM ALWAYS TO
THE SAME OUTCOME AND SAME
AGENDA.
THE SECOND DISTURBING THING IS
THE QUESTION OF HOW IT IS THAT
NOT JUST CNN BUT ULTIMATELY CBS
AND MSNBC THAT SAID THEY
CONFIRMED THE STORY GOT I WRONG.
THEY ALL CLAIMED THAT MULTIPLE
SOURCES TOLD THEM THAT THIS
PUBLICATIONS BECAME PUBLIC.
HOW DID ALL SOURCES GET THE SAME
DATE WRONG WHEN TALKING TO
MULTIPLE MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS?
>> Laura: GLENN, THEY REFUSED TO
SAY OVER THE WEEKEND WHEN THEY
TROTTED OUT CARL BERNSTEIN WHO
HAS BEEN DINING OUT ON WATERGATE
FOR 40 PLUS YEARS, THEY WON'T
IF MULTIPLE SOURCES -- I THINK
THE DATE WAS THE -- MISSING ONE
DIGIT.
THE 4th OR THE 14th, SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
GIVEN THAT CASE, HOW COULD
MULTIPLE PEOPLE READ A NUMBER
ON ITS LEGAL FACE SEEMS
FAR-FETCHED.
>> RIGHT.
SEEMS LIKE IT'S A DELIBERATE
ATTEMPT TO MISLEAD, IN WHICH
THEY HAVE THE OBLIGATION TO SAY
WHICH MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
PROBABLY DEMOCRATS ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE ARE THE
ONES THAT GAVE THEM THAT FALSE
INFORMATION.
IF IT WASN'T DELIBERATE, THEY
HAVE THE OBLIGATION TO SAY HOW
EMPLOYEES, CARL BERNSTEIN AND
DAVID FROMM TO PRETEND THEY WERE
WILLING TO TALK ABOUT IT.
THEY DIDN'T BRING ME ON WHEN I
TALK ABOUT FOX NEWS AND THE
HUMILIATIONS THAT HAVE TAKEN
PLACE THIS YEAR, CNN IMMEDIATELY
INVITES ME ON AND FOX DOESN'T.
FOX LOVES TO HAVE ME ON AND CNN
WON'T.
THAT IS THE ISSUE.
FOX HAS HAD THEIR SHARE OF
MISTAKE ALSO IN THE DIRECTION OF
THE PROBLEM IS THAT MEAD
THE PROBLEM IS THAT MEDI
THE PROBLEM IS THAT MEDIA
OUTLETS ARE VULCANIZED.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY TRANSPARENCY
AND THAT IS WHAT IS RUINING
JOURNALISM.
>> FIRST OF ALL, IF I GET
SOMETHING WRONG, GLENN, YOU HAVE
AN OPEN INVITATION TO CORRECT
ME.
IF I GET SOMETHING WRONG, I'M
HAPPY TO HAVE YOU ON AND HAVE A
ABOUT THERE.
I WANT MORE PEOPLE ON MY SHOW.
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TROUBLE
GETTING PEOPLE THAT ARE
DEMOCRATS ON THE SHOW OR
LIBERALS.
I'M ALWAYS WELCOMING MORE
VOICES.
I'M HAPPY TO HAVE YOU ON FOR
THAT.
IT'S NOT JUST CNN.
WE HAVE "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
COMING OUT WITH STORIES THAT
THEY HAVE TO CORRECT.
OBVIOUSLY CBS, "WASHINGTON POST"
REPEATS THE FALSE STORIES THAT
OTHER NETWORKS ARE PRINTING.
SOMETIMES WHAT THEY SAY IS
THERE'S A RUSH TO GET NEWS OUT.
IT'S JUST BECAUSE OF THE SPEED
OF THE INTERNET.
IS THAT A PLAUSIBLE EXPLANATION
HERE?
PEOPLE WERE MAKING MISTAKES
BECAUSE THEY WERE RUSHING, YOU'D
EXPECT 50% TO GO IN ONE
DIRECTION AND 50% TO GO IN THE
OTHER DIRECTION.
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE IS THE
OPPOSITE.
100% OF THE MISTAKES THAT
OUTLETS LIKE CNN AND "THE
WASHINGTON POST" AND MSNBC MAKE
ARE DESIGNED TO SUBVERT DONALD
TRUMP AND BOLSTER THE RUSSIA
TRUMP STORY LIKE ALL OF FOX'S
MISTAKES ARE IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION.
I DON'T MEAN YOU SHOW, BUT THE
TWO THAT DONALD TRUMP LIKES TO
WATCH, WHAT IS THE MORNING SHOW
FULL OF DISINFORMATION AND THE
SHOW THAT PRECEDES YOURS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM IN
JOURNALISM.
THESE MISTAKES STOP LOOKING LIKE
MISTAKES WHEN THEY GO IN THE
SAME DIRECTION AND BOLSTERING
MEDIA OUTLETS.
>> Laura: I HAVE A QUESTION ON
SOMETHING COMPLETELY UNRELATED.
BECAUSE YOU REALLY PUSH FOR
TRANSPARENCY IN VARIOUS
ALLEGED WRONGDOING, DO YOU THINK
THAT IN CASES LIKE WITH AL
FRANKEN THAT WOMEN AND MEN THAT
YOU THINK THAT IS FAIR?
>> NO IT'S TERRIBLY UNFAIR.
A COUPLE MONTHS AGO, THERE WAS A
DOCUMENT THAT WAS CIRCULATING
AROUND THE INTERNET THAT
PURPORTED TO IDENTIFY MEN IN THE
MEDIA WHO HAD MISBEHAVED WITH
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AND ENTIRELY
ANONYMOUS.
EVERYONE IN THE MEDIA READ IT.
PEOPLE TALKED ABOUT IT.
IT'S SO OFFENSIVE AS A LAWYER,
IF YOU CARE ABOUT DUE PROCESS, A
HUMAN BEING THAT CARES ABOUT
ETHICS AND BASIC FAIRNESS TO
ALLOW PEOPLE ACCUSED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DEFENSE
THEMSELVES, WHICH THEY CAN'T DO,
IF THEY'RE BEING SMEARED WITH
ANONYMOUS ATTACKS.
>> Laura: I THINK, GLENN,
TEN YEARS AGO, 20 YEARS AGO, 30
YEARS AGO AND ALL I'M SAYING IS
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE AN ABILITY TO
RESPOND, AND IT'S REALLY HARD TO
PROVE OR DISPROVE THINGS THAT
HAVE HAPPENED MANY YEARS AGO.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR MEN OR
WOMEN AND I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE HURT OUT THERE.
AT SOME POINT WE HAVE TO HAVE
SOME DUE PROCESS BEFORE WE